♪ ♪
>> Bret: THIS EVENING WE
INTRODUCE YOU TO A YOUNG MAN WHO
WANTS TO MAKE HISTORY.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL HAS HIS STORY
TONIGHT.
>> MADISON COBBLED IS AIMING
BECOME THE YOUNGEST PERSON
ELECTED TO CONGRESS SINCE THE
LATE 1700s.
THE FIRST MOOD WAS TO DEFEAT HIS
OPPONENT WHICH HE DID
OVERWHELMINGLY.
THE SECOND IS PRETTY EASILY
YOU’LL BE ORDER ENOUGH TO SOAR
WHEN HE TURNS 25 ON AUGUST 1ST.
TRUMP AND THE MAN SEATED FEELING
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS
ACTUALLY BACKED HIS PRIMARY
OPPONENT ABOUT TUESDAY AT THE
RESIDENCE INVITATION, HE BROUGHT
HIS FAMILY TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT’S NOT A REFERENDUM ON
TRUMP IN THE ENDORSEMENT AND SO
HE WAS REALLY AWARE OF THE DAY
AND HE’S EXCITED TO GET TO WORK
WITH US.
>> GET A CHANCE ENCOUNTER WITH
SENATOR GRAHAM AND RUDY GIULIANI
VISITING HIM AT TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL HOTEL.
ALSO MAKING THE ROUNDS OF
LEADING REPUBLICANS.
>> THERE IMPRESSED WITH HOW WE
ARE LEADING THE CAMPAIGN.
THE SPEAKER A MEMBER OF GENESEE,
HE SAYS THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS STRUGGLING TO REACH HIS
PEERS.
>> THERE TRYING TO DEFUSE IF
THEY’RE UNABLE TO.
>> HE CAN SPEAK TO YOUNG VOTERS
AND BE HELPFUL TO THE GLP.
>> WE WANT TO LIVE OUR LIVES.
>> I ASKED ABOUT THE REEF SENT
CONFEDERATE NAMES AND STATUE.
>> THAT’S NOT GOING TO BE
DECIDED BY IMPERFECT PEOPLE.
>> MOST OF THE MATURITY COMES
FROM HE WAS NEARLY KILLED IN A
CAR ACCIDENT SIX TEEN YEARS AGO.
>> HE BELIEVES HE’S HERE FOR A
REASON.
>> I HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LORD DECIDED
TO PROTECT MY MIND AND MY
ABILITY TO SPEAK AND NOW I’VE
GOT THIS MOTIVATION AND THIS
PASSION, THE ZEAL TO REALIZE OUR